I wanted to wait until the weekend was over before
posting this uh because I want to give you all a
chance to watch Black Adam but now that plenty
of you have I wanted to make it official that I
am back as Superman and the image you see on
this post and what you saw in Black Adam are
just a very small taste of things to come
so uh there's a lot to be thankful for and
I'll get to that in time but I want to
thank you guys most of all thank you
for your support and thank you for your
patience I promise it will be rewarded
Henry I have a question when we first did Man
of Steel and we were doing the flying shots for
the first time and we put you in the belly pan or
on the wires I can't remember which we did first
did feel odd to be you know just there in front
of green screen doing your flying you know shots
you know with us just touching the camera and uh
you having to act like you're flying up you know
before you had ever seen what it might look like
or what it might feel like was that how was that
was that odd or and did you expect it to turn
out the way it came so that's my question um
I can't wait to work with you in the future
and you are of course the greatest Superman
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my new
Henry Cavill Superman Man of Steel 2 video about
him coming back officially long term as Superman
in the DC movies and them actually making Man of
Steel we heard about this a couple years ago but
now it is finally official it's actually a thing
and as I was in the process of putting this
video together this week James Gunn was also
named as the new Kevin feige of all DC meaning
he's going to be in charge of all the upcoming
movies and DC shows so I'll explain how that's
going to work during the video too in long time
fans have been joking about an Avengers versus
Justice League Marvel DC crossover turns out
they could actually do something like that
now because you have James Gunn running DC
calling those shots okay stuff like that if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos the future is looking so much
brighter for DC just in general like so much good
news after all the bad news we've had the last
couple of years quite rightly otherwise I probably
shouldn't deserve to wear the the cape but I
never gave up hope and it's amazing to be here now
uh talking about it again um there is such a
bright future ahead for the character and I'm
so excited to tell a story with a an enormously
joyful Superman literally the best possible
thing that could have happened like Henry Cavill
coming back long term all the Black Adam stuff
seeming like it's worked out for Henry Cavill and
everybody involved and DC finally finding a person
with a proven track record and create a vision to
oversee the future of the movies who's not just
like a pure executive which it sounds like they've
kind of had in the past but the biggest news first
obviously is the Henry Cavill news so careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen Black Adam I'm
assuming most of you know what's going on even
if you haven't seen the movie I've already done
a couple of Black Adams Superman post-credits
scene videos full breakdowns and Easter eggs
for the entire movie so I will link those down in
the description below and at the end of this but
Henry Cavill comes back as dceu Superman even
though technically they're calling it the DCU
now like as part of all this they're calling it
the DC Universe not the DC extended universe and
they're calling it DC Studios which sounds just
like Marvel Studios because it's the same basic
type of organization but Henry Cavill is coming
back is the Canon Superman like this is all Canon
to the previous dceu stuff that Zack Snyder
stuff that he's done before and he did a much
longer public talk recently addressing everything
in Greater detail like okay like let's talk about
me coming back now what does this mean for the
future Zack Snyder even sent in a clip for that
special event where he referenced him always being
Superman to him that's the video that I put at the
beginning of this because he's the person who
originally cast Henry Cavill they spent so much
time working on the character Superman together
during the talk Henry Cavill also addressed his
future appearances in crossovers I'm so excited to
tell a story with a an enormously joyful Superman
he'll feel more like you would expect Superman to
feel tonally like he won't be the sad Boy Superman
or anything like that the Black Adam post-credit
scene was like 10 seconds super quick obviously
that's going to become a much bigger thing in
the future like he'll come back for much larger
appearances and then finally in Man of Steel 2.
whatever they wind up calling that movie it won't
be called Mana still too but that's the basic way
you talk about it right now like right now it is
the next movie in his franchise of films they're
not completely rebooting everything with Superman
in a traditional sense they're still treating
everything like it happened everything is still
Canon without completely referencing everything
every five seconds this always the biggest
question like is everything Canon now like are
they changing anything are they retuning anything
if you're a big fan of the Charlie Cox version
of Daredevil it's the same basic deal with Henry
Cavill Superman and all his future appearances
like they might retune the suit just like a little
bit in some of his new appearances and refresh
it again during the next Man of Steel movie but
all the stuff that happened to him during the
first Man of Steel movie Batman v Superman the
Justice League movie that will all still be Canon
and just to be clear none of the stuff with Henry
Cavill Coming Back in Black Adam to the larger DC
Universe of Superman has anything to do with James
Gunn taking over with DC that's a totally separate
thing it's just a coincidence that both of those
things happened at the same time if you've been
following this news for a long time James Gunn
said that the first time he actually met with
Warner Brothers about potentially doing a new
movie obviously he did The Suicide Squad movie
but when he met with him for the first time it
was just sort of a general meeting to see what he
was interested in the Warner Brothers Executives
specifically pitched to him doing a new Superman
movie they basically told him he could do anything
that he wanted any kind of movie use any kind of
character they pitched him Batman as well because
this was before they had locked down matt Reeves
for the next Batman movie he obviously chose to do
The Suicide Squad characters because that's more
of his Vibe doing the C and d-list characters like
the Guardians of the Galaxy type of energy with DC
characters but for like a brief hot second there
was a chance that James Gunn could have done a
new Superman movie and no I do not think that
James Gunn is going to direct the Man of Steel 2
movie I think that that'll be somebody completely
different even though he's taking over all of DC
he'll still have his own side projects that he
works on himself like Peacemaker season two he's
working on some other spin-offs in some other DC
movies but those will be more like the movies
that you typically expect him to do but given
that he is taking over DC he will creatively
oversee whichever director and writers they
hire to do Man of Steel too right now the talk is
that the Christopher McCrory pitched that he had
a long time ago with Henry Cavill is back in the
mix Christopher McCrory said that he had a pitch
that he and Henry Cavill came up with for a Man
of Steel too it was rejected at the time by the
previous powers that be but they've all either
been fired or quit and that has a lot to do with
Henry Cavill being able to come back in the first
place in the Black Adam movie like how the rock
was able to get him to come back because finding
out what actually went down behind the scenes it
actually turns out the rock had to put somebody
in a Chokehold to get Henry Cavill in the Black
Adam movie in the first place so credit where
credit is due the rock is responsible for Henry
Cavill coming back and then that was sort of like
the back door to him coming back for even bigger
stuff Man of Steel 2 all the other stuff that
they have planned now I think Black Adam lands the
first punch now I don't know Black Adam lands the
last punch uh because Superman I grew up a DC boy
Superman I love Superman I loved Superman and I
still do I was also listening to the fans at the
same time where you have Black Adam we will create
Black Adam for him to be the most powerful and
Unstoppable force on this planet the most powerful
and Unstoppable force in the entire universe has
been on the sidelines for too long so the rock
really wanting Henry Cavill this whole time these
last several years he was trying to get the movie
made along with the new Warner Brothers Discovery
CEO that obviously has done a lot of controversial
things like he's canceled a lot of stuff as well
during his presentation he specifically shouted
out this new focus on doing more Superman stuff
so clearly the company wanted to do more Superman
stuff and you have the rock that's trying to make
Black Adam a much bigger thing in pushing for
Henry kappel who has a lot of power over his
own films so that's how they landed the giant
Henry Cavill Superman size W so you take those
W's when you can get them as far as the plan for
future Superman stuff the next couple of years the
rocket said that Black Adam 2 currently isn't
intended to be just the Superman vs Black Adam
movie he's not totally sure how they're going to
pay off that fight but they will pay it off now
they're in the process of actually banging out a
much bigger Longer term deal for Henry Cavill so
they can actually start making Man of Steel
too because of all the DC stuff that's been
canceled or pushed off recently reportedly what
happened is they canceled plans for a Supergirl
HBO's series with that new version of Supergirl
and now she's just gonna stay Multiverse like
she's still going to be part of the upcoming
movies but they're not making her like the de
facto only super person on screen Henry Cavill
is coming back as your main version of Superman
on the main Earth so when we get to The Flash
movie he might be wearing a different version
of the costume when we get to Man of Steel too
they'll probably creatively retune the costume
just a little bit again no big surprise there
just to explain all the James Gunn stuff yes he
is taking over DC but that's really not going to
happen until he releases Guardians of the Galaxy
3 Kevin feige specifically did an interview about
this he was very congratulatory he was like the
first person to congratulate James Gunn he said
he'd be the first person in line to see all the
stuff that he did we have a wonderful thing called
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special coming
out we have a wonderful thing called guardians
galaxy vol 3 coming out in May how will we have
any time to work on DC until May I don't know but
once he does have the time I'll be very excited
and first in line but only after he finished
working on all the Marvel commitments that
he has right now like the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special and Guardians of Galaxy 3 like he
is very busy but as soon as he's done working on
our stuff I cannot wait to see what he does at DC
that just means that James Gunn won't do a lot of
heavy lifting at DC in his new role until spring
next year after Guardians the Galaxy 3 comes out
in theaters his partner Peter Safran who's done
a bunch of previous DC movies is doing more of
the business stuff like the financial side of all
the DC movies and shows now James Gunn is doing
more the Kevin feige thing where he's more of the
creative vision working on more of the creative
aspect of everything if you have any other Henry
Cavill Superman questions or James Gunn questions
that I didn't address during this just write them
Below in the comments and a lot of my future
bonus videos Everyone click here for that Black
Adam post credit scene video and click here for
my new Ant-Man in the wasp Quantumania trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys in the next one!